one man's death has provoked a movement
for change what began with the killing
of George Floyd is now a global moment
of reckoning with pressure to confront
racism once and for all
tonight on Sky News we focus on race and
revolution and ask is change going to
come
[Music]
[Music]
good evening I'm Gillian Joseph over the
next hour we'll discuss how the debate
around racism is changing and what more
needs to be done joining us the
Hollywood actor David or yellow whose
credits include the role of Martin
Luther King in Selma with questions
being raised around the lack of
diversity at senior levels across
society we're joined by one of the UK's
leading advertising executives and
senior government adviser Karen Blackett
plus the historian and award-winning
filmmaker professor David Ono shoga and
completing our quartet the former
government minister and first black
Conservative MP to attend the cabinet
Sam Jima facing them the live virtual
studio audience will be asking questions
about how racism can be driven from
society so statues have fallen thousands
have protested millions have joined a
new conversation all prompted by the
killing and those desperate dying
breaths of George Floyd
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't want the narrative to change to
something ugly
why would I walk past that every day
makes me feel like I don't matter
enough is enough which is driving for a
poly not nothing else here change didn't
happen in London by could happen in
London it has happen in London we want
to see four officers prosecuted
incentives we think that because we're
not as socially racist as America is
that we are innocent we are not
no more hate prize please win has
america ever been great
[Applause]
hopefully George's looking down right
now and say there's a great thing that's
happening for our country
[Applause]
[Applause]
in America and the passionate words of
Reverend Al Sharpton they're conveying
the determination that this time things
are going to change but tragically
George Floyd's name joins an
ever-growing list of black men whose
killings were supposed to usher in a new
era of racial equality in America
especially eight years ago that name was
Trayvon Martin a 17 year old from
Florida shot as he walked home and whose
death became a focal point for anti
racism campaigners across the United
States Trayvon's mother Sybrina Fulton
joins us live now from Miami welcome to
you it's hard to believe that it's
already eight years since Trayvon
skilling how are you I'm doing well I
can actually say I'm doing fairly well
how did you feel when you you saw those
images that have been played out across
our screens of George Floyd being killed
it's heartbreaking it's disgusting to
know that we're still being treated like
animals like we're three-fifths human
and it was awful it was awful to hear
George seeing what happened to him
such disrespect and to know that he was
calling out for his
who was already in heaven and what sort
of memories did it bring back for you oh
it brought memories back of my son and
the tragic you know death that he had
and just to known there's so many people
are supporting George Floyd and you know
I stand with him as well I stand with
his family as well just so I can do my
part to you know just make sure that my
voice is heard I definitely feel like
change is going to come that was one of
the things that I heard in the clip that
you just played most definitely change
is going to come but we have to keep the
pressure on and make sure that we have
laws in place and make sure that we make
the necessary changes so people don't
continue to treat us a certain way and
talking about keeping that that pressure
on a year after Trayvon was killed the
black lives matter movement would was
set up and you've started the Trayvon
Martin foundation do you think that
group action makes a difference
absolutely absolutely absolutely think
that you know the voice of so many
different people from all walks of life
it doesn't matter if you're poor middle
class or rich if you're educated or
uneducated it doesn't matter if you're a
Christian Baptist Muslim a Jewish it
doesn't matter those things it doesn't
matter if you're straight or gay those
things are not are important what's
important is that these are human beings
that we all are human beings and we
shouldn't treat each other
accordingly we should treat each other
and respect each other no matter what
your religion is no matter what the
carve your skin is as we know that the
debate around criminal justice continues
today we've had Donald Trump the
President of the United States signing
an executive order restricting police
use of chokehold do you welcome that has
that gone far enough for you concern is
said unless it was necessary or they
fear for their life if you know we have
had people being shot in the back and I
don't understand you know
some of the things some of the language
that Lauren force may uses and you know
some of the language that even the
president used today you know it could
be questionable but I just think that
people need to stop killing us for no
reason it whatever George Floyd here he
should have been arrested for it and not
it should not have cost in his life you
attended that the funeral of a George
Floyd obviously you witnessed that the
grief the loss and and the anger do you
think that his killing is a tipping
point is something different this time
the difference I see now is a lot of
young people are involved in that's a
plus a lot of people from all walks of
life and involved in it was recorded on
video so the narrative would have been a
little differently had we not had a
video we would have heard that that
George Floyd resisted arrest so that he
was belligerent or something like that
and in the officer feared for his life
but that's not what we saw because of
the video we were able to see and he was
handcuffed he was on the ground
his face was pressing the ground he was
calling out that he couldn't breathe he
was calling out for his mother while he
was being restrained by three officers
in the fourth officer were standing
there and so all people all parties
involved me to be held accountable
regardless whenever there's a loss of
life they need to be held accountable
Sybrina Fulton thank you very much for
speaking to us this evening well maybe
there is a difference this time and the
global reaction to the killing of George
Floyd including of course in the UK will
finally provide a catalyst for change so
lots to discuss with our panel then so
let's get our first question from our
virtual audience first up is Yasmin a
motor show from but Coast Hill in ethics
what is your question yes ma'am good
evening through my work as a barrister I
often find that black men are
disproportionately targeted by the
police and are more likely to have force
use against them by police officers
this has fatally damaged community
police relations
and cause too many within black
communities to distrust the police what
are the practical ways the police can
establish trust with black communities
in the UK and Yasmin you've come into
this this area from your your daily
experiences through your your profession
is that right I have yes
okay let's take that to the panel that
question from Yasmin if we go to Sam
Jima first of all Sam Yasmin saying that
disproportionately black people are
disturbed by the criminal justice system
there is a lot in that and not just in
terms of community policing but
certainly if you look at incarceration
rates or and a number of our black men
specifically in prison and black youths
it is very high and I think she asked
about specific things that could be done
and Gleeson works when it is by consent
and when the police work hand in glove
with the community rather than against
the community and I think that's what we
need to focus on the more community
policing but specifically around things
like stop and search where the where
reforms if several years ago to
basically stop the police just stopping
anyone in search in them which sort of
led to some of the harassment that I
think Yasmin is referring to and I think
most senior police men agree that there
are ways of dealing with things like
stopping search without necessarily
going to the lens that some policemen do
and therefore harassing young men I
think that is it but the big point you
made in your program is this is yet
another watershed in racial injustice
and we don't want there to be another
one we need reform and we need perform
across the board now Karen blackett how
can police establish trust with the
black community here in the UK but there
is a formula which is in the book the
trusted adviser that talks about
trust equals credibility plus
reliability plus empathy / self
orientation so I think the cool thing
that we need to see more of is that
empathy and I think it's exactly what
was just being said in terms of actually
understanding your audience
understanding the fruit salad that is
modern Britain having more of a
connection helps build empathy I mean
that speak for themselves as your
audience member has said you know more
like 10 times more likely to be stopped
and searched five times more likely to
be arrested 3 times more likely to have
force used on them when arrested so I
generally think there is a disconnect
between the police and some communities
and you help build trust by having
greater empathy and it's going back to
that trust equation for me David a
yellow where how do you build that
empathy that Karen's talking about well
I think that there are a lot of things
one can do in the immediate obviously
but you know III think of this in in a
more long-term sense what we are dealing
with in terms of racism in the UK in
America and across the world
is tied to systems of oppression that
have existed for centuries a lot of the
problem is education I think you have
Britain as a company as a country in my
opinion that has done a terrible job of
educating the young educating the
society in terms of who black people
actually are and who we have been
historically that the legacy of
colonialism Britain's participation in
the enslavement of black people and if
you are able to really start to break
down what these systems of oppression
have been over centuries and the
discrepancy between who we actually are
as
and brown people and who we are
perceived to be I think a breaking down
of those preconceptions are what are
going to eventually with time mean that
we have a more equitable society because
a lot of the time what you're dealing
with is when it comes to the police is
them dealing with their notion of who we
are as black and brown people as opposed
to who we actually are and that ties
back to education so even though there
is policy that can come in at this time
I think a more long-term view needs to
be taken in terms of changing the
perception of who we are as black and
brown people who are participating
rightfully in British life
you mentioned their education we're
going to be speaking a little bit more
about that later on in the program but
you've spoken very passionately about
this subject and you shared some of your
feelings I hope you don't mind us
showing a clip of what you posted on
social media David I'm just recording
this having just
having just watched George Floyd funeral
where everyone was asked to be silent
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds and that is
such a long time it is such a long time
to have a man's knee on your neck
ah please let the future not be the same
for my son as it has been for my dad for
me and for so many black people over the
centuries that's actually really
difficult to watch David and those in
the studio audience affected by that but
you get a real sense of how deeply felt
this is for you well when I talk there
about the long time 8 minutes and 46
seconds there was so much about Derrick
shervin's knee on George Floyd's neck
that was symbolic of what we as black
people have had to endure for centuries
whether it's the enslavement of black
people whether it's the colonization of
so much of Africa and what we still
endure now in modern life and how long
we have been begging pleading imploring
that we be seen as fully human there is
this phrase that has crept into our
parlance now which is gaslighting you
are made to feel insane as a black
person by by calling out these things
and one of the jewels in the crown when
it comes to systems of oppression is
making the oppressed feel like they are
lying feel like they are complaining
feel like they have a narrative in their
head that doesn't correlate with reality
it's what happens to people who are
enduring domestic abuse the abuser
convinces them that they are
exaggerating it's what we have done
traditionally to women who have been
raped in even in the judicial system
we we have made it so that they don't
don't feel able to cry out because we
distrust them on the basis of the
evidence that they are giving that they
are being harmed
and this has been the case for black and
brown people for so long and in the UK
particularly talking about racism you
are made to feel like you're playing the
race card it's not something that truly
exists and it's because so much of
Britain's bad behavior has taken place
on other continents in Africa in in in
in America but Britain did a pretty
incredible job of building and
perfecting those systems before farming
them out to the world and he asked me
not knowing I had an agreement there
also professor all of sugar saw you
nodding your head also yeah I mean I do
me you can discuss this without
discussing history I mean there's a
reason why we have a particular problem
in this country with the police and
that's because the police has its own
history its own history of for example
sending officers to the dying Empire in
the 50s and 60s who came back with their
ideas its own history of being involved
in the investigations and the drawing up
of reports in the 1950s again
investigations into the black community
investigations to try to prove the case
against the black community and
therefore the case for racial
integration laws the police have a very
specific problem in Britain which in
some ways is just a microcosm of the
bigger problem which is the black people
are treated with suspicion black
people's backstories are not told and
that that history has created a culture
which is it odds with many aspects of
the rest of the rest of the care of the
country what black people experience
when they're stopped by the police when
they encounter criminal justice system
is people they don't see them as
individuals a system that can't see them
as individuals and to encounter that
situation and to realize that no matter
what you've done or who you are or what
you've achieved none of that matters
because you're not you you are what they
perceive you to be
that is almost uniquely damaging okay at
that point I want to bring Yasmin back
in and Yasmin do you think what from
what we've heard from the panel there
that there's a realistic prospect of the
police building a new
relationship if you like with the black
community well firstly the answers are
just so terrific and I think there needs
to be an acknowledgement first and
foremost that there is an issue and
there doesn't appear to have been that
yet so that needs to be the starting
point and only then can empathy even be
gauged at all um there's hope but from
this point I'm not entirely sure
unfortunately okay he has been hopeful
there let's have a look at some of the
statistics for you shall we because they
make up some pretty stark reading black
people make up around 3% of the
population but 13% of the prison
population last year black people were
more than nine times more likely to be
stopped and searched than white people
but at the other end of the criminal
justice system just 1% of court judges
in England and Wales are black so just
1% of judges in the criminal justice
system are black Sam G Madhu those stats
shock you they they don't because this
is a story that we've all been aware of
for very long time that you know whether
it's not just in the criminal justice
system whether it's journalism whether
it's academia whether it's the civil
service certainly in terms of those who
are on the top very consistent with the
criminal justice system and what is
shocking is we're still talking about
this in 2020 what is shocking is after
several reviews you know everything
there was there Lamy review into the
criminal justice system which was the
last one we don't we still don't feel
confident that we're anywhere close to
actually addressing this issue and that
there were some people I know who
reacted to George Floyd's tragic death
by saying well that's an American issue
it's not an issue for Britain we are
different we don't have the same
problems here but we do have our own
problems
we do have a shadow side to our
history and to what is going on
currently and so to your question is it
shocking no it's not but what's
remarkable is that it's not shocking
because we've all known this for a very
long time Karen black hit I was brought
up a child of the 70s in reading and my
mum and dad came to the EAA in 1961 my
mum was a nurse my dad an electrical
engineer and worked for BT and they had
two daughters myself and my sister and I
was told from a very early age you have
to try twice as hard to get half as much
that things are stacked against you
you're a woman and you're a black woman
so the statistics don't surprise me
where and I think of my world and the
world of business and the advertising
community we are responsible and help
shape culture we do we help shape what
is seen as the cultural norms and if I
think about my industry less than 5% of
leaders and the CEOs of the advertisers
in the industry in the UK come from a
black or minority ethnic backgrounds so
our job is to betray consumer stories as
part of a brand story there's not not
enough diversity to be able to portray
those stories in a real way and in an
authentic way so the statistics don't
[ __ ] me I am stato so I tend to look a
lot at data and I can see it from my own
industry which is a microcosm of what's
going on in this country and what's
going on globally the the way of being
able to get to the top to remove
barriers to be in those senior roles is
stacked against us it really is because
people tend to hire in their own mirror
image it's no coincidence that there's
just four black CEOs in the fortune 500
and there's one black footsie 100 C and
that says it all yeah
bring in some more unfavorable stats and
lots of agreement from our audience
there I'd like to bring in another
audience member now so I Rita hair were
- who's has a story that I suspect and
it's pertinent to it - a lot of black
people sorry - what what's your
experience um so basically I'm also from
reading say hello myself and my daughter
went along to a well-known retailer not
so long ago and we watched as soon as we
walked in the door all the way through
when we were stopping to look at things
when we were even paying all the way
through - when we walked out the door it
makes you feel like a criminal even
though you know that you're not and the
worst thing was previously I'd gone in
dressed in work attire and hadn't been
looked at Adam but it's that presumption
it's the fact that my daughter and
myself had to go through that on a daily
basis and I find it shocking and sad
sorry so thank you for sharing your
experience with us David Oyelowo the
everyday experiences that black people
have to go through and now coming to the
fore can you share yours with us well in
line with what Karen just said about her
industry my industry is is disgraceful
shameful shocking statistically speaking
when it comes to the representation of
black people and it is doubly insidious
because a lot of how the world imbibes
culture has a notion of what the world
is is through television and film and
entertainment generally so you know what
the lady just said there about her her
experience may be shocking to some but
the unfortunate thing is that it's not
shocking to a black person the thing
that I keep going back to is systems of
oppression we are in the midst of
someone described it to me the other day
that we are born into a racist container
in the in the West we are born
into something that is not necessarily
who we are but how we are and what we do
and what we think is dictated by that
racist container we are born into and it
is designed what we did the thing that I
really want people and especially white
people to understand why people who bulk
at the notion of white supremacy and
white privilege as terminology that is
now crept into society they need to just
come to terms with the fact that they're
there is design in this what that lady
just had in that store is tantamount to
what happens in a police state that is
what enabled apartheid to to be rife for
so long it is the line you can draw
between the slave catchers when black
people were enslaved in America to the
sharecroppers who had slave catchers
there who literally from from from
firmance from slavery to sharecropping
to the prison industrial complex
policing and a police state and how
black people have been policed there is
a direct line and as black people in the
world we experience either heavy-handed
versions of that or mild versions of
that and it is all tied to perpetuating
the notion of white supremacy which is
tied to power which is tied to a certain
demographic in the world retaining that
power and so every time you go into a
store and you are watched somehow you
are in the COG of this wheel that is
making you feel like you are lesser than
and Britain we all sort of talk about
the class system the upper class the
middle class the working class
that is a system of oppression to keep
people in their place when you look at
the Granville Tower and you see that
nearly half of the people who died in
that tragedy were black and brown people
it is not a mistake we are dealing with
something
that is by design and until that design
until those structures until those
mechanisms are dismantled and rebuilt I
don't know how we move forward because
reform tends to be a band-aid on a
bullet wound that's why I keep on going
back to education I don't know if you
can see David but applause from our
studio audience who've been listening to
what you had to say and we're gonna see
now how widespread these issues are and
how they differ for white and black
people I want to do a bit of an
experiment so I'm going to ask everyone
in the audience and our panelists as
well to put your hand up in front of
your face so that we can see the palm of
your hand have you all done that okay so
now I'm going to ask a series of
questions and I want you to put a finger
down each time okay let's go for it
first question put a finger down if
you've been called a racial slur or have
been racially abused okay finger down if
you've been given or have given the
coming-of-age talk about how to behave
when stopped by the police put a finger
down if you've been stopped by police
for no valid reason put a finger down if
someone has assumed you are the cleaner
or driver put a finger down if someone
has expressed surprise at how articulate
you are put a finger down if you've been
asked where are you really from
so nearly all the black fists are
clenched no fingers left and I think
almost almost all the that the white
hands still remaining with all fingers
and on our panel I see that Karen has
one finger the only one with one finger
raised there Karen are you surprised by
the visual representation of our
audience there that clearly showed
perhaps what we have come to know and is
common parlance now as white privilege I
am I'm not surprised at all and that
doesn't mean that I don't believe that
there are some brilliant allies that
exist but I am not surprised because
it's not their lives it's not something
that they've experienced and what I have
seen over the last few weeks since the
killing of George Floyd is actually more
allies trying to understand so I agree
with David's point about education and
its education for everyone I can't be
responsible for educating everybody that
has exhibited and has benefited from
white privilege you've got to educate
yourself as well so it's not a surprise
unfortunately I think maybe compared to
the other panelists as a black female
some of the questions that you've asked
I haven't experienced all of them but
the fact that you know most of the panel
had all of their fingers down it's no
surprise same with our studio audience
yeah important that you made that
distinction about being a black woman
the experiences of black women and men
are quite different let's take a
question from our audience now this time
from Ben Shahn Ruby Ben what's your
question
I could evening so my question is quite
simple why is it difficult for some
people to see statues of men brought
down when their lives when their wealth
was built on the backs of slaves Ben
before I put that question to the panel
and what's your view of this this
argument that's raging now over statues
so the first of
whether believed in vandalism it's not
good to vandalize anything but when it
comes to the point of statues we have to
look at the historical value of those
statues when it snow and Britain as a
country needs to understand what those
statues represent because they will
represent different things of different
people if the what we're actually seeing
now is that we're statues and things
were the one that's happened quite
recently we've taken a few of what that
actually is and they've gone through the
the means and ways of trying to rectify
and see what that actually was in the
statue but it didn't take course so now
we're having to take it down and the
people are actually rising up so
actually take action to their enhance
okay Ben thank you for that so remind of
Ben's question why is it difficult for
some people to see statues of men
brought down
when their wealth was built on the backs
of slaves professor on a sugar I think
this one is for you Bristow lien let us
know first of all what your thoughts
were when you saw that statue of Edward
Coulston brought down well I was sad
they came to that it should never have
come to that because there have been
decades and decades have attempts to
persuade the council in this city and
I'm talking to you from Bristol to
remove that statue this is a city that's
14 percent non-white it's about 6
percent African Caribbean that means all
of those subject of the city who were
the descendants of enslaved people have
been asked for decades to live their
lives under the gaze of somebody who
enslaved we estimate around 80 thousand
people and we estimate about nineteen
that nineteen thousand of them died in
the Middle Passage to ask people to
tolerate that to swallow the pain it
causes them is a profound act of
disrespect so while I don't come down
the pulling down of status I will not
condemn those who took part in it
because every possible alternative was
rebuffed and ignored and I think that's
because the people in power and the city
were convinced that this would never
happen and they weren't they were wrong
what's happening today in Bristol is
quite incredible the the memorials they
are dimensions the way
édouard costs in the slave trader his
name was imprinted in this city his
image of hearing in the stained glass
windows of two of the city's churches
his name on buildings on a concert hall
all of that in the space about 48 hours
has been wiped away I've lived in the
city 22 years and I've been told that
was impossible the city would never turn
its back on the great philanthropist
they would never remember his role in
the Atlantic slave trade they only
remember his philanthropy it's all
happened in about 48 hours it's gone
remarkable let's listen to the words or
actually read you the words of the Prime
Minister on this subject something he's
had a lot to say about it's not just
that it's wrong to destroy public
property by violence I'm also extremely
dubious about the growing campaign to
edit or Photoshop the entire cultural
landscape if we start purging the record
and removing the images of all but those
whose attitudes conform to our own we're
engaged in a great lie a distortion of
our history Sam Jima is it a distortion
of our history if we aim to bring down
statues of previous slavers I think the
first thing I'll say is I absolutely
agree with what was done in Bristol
because there had been several attempts
to get rid of that statue through
democratic processes right to bring the
statue down in the manner that they did
I think vandalism no but I can totally
understand why they did it and but what
I think going back to what I said early
is we've got to be able to discuss our
history waltz in all and that means
being comfortable at the dark side of
empire as well as all the other aspects
of it and in the absence of doing that
you get the situation where there is
frustration about statues and people
wanting to express that frustration and
that anger through cooling down statues
my own view though is
there if we are to deal with the issues
of racial injustice in our society today
and the future hard univer which 19th
century statue iki doesn't get us closer
to solving the problems in the criminal
justice system doesn't get us closer to
addressing the deep inequalities in
education doesn't get us closer to allah
enabling people to fulfill their
potential if they are in work which is
the case where a lot of black and brown
people they don't the either not in work
way there and where not many of them
fulfill their potential so yes we should
discuss our history we should discuss
the dark side of it and we should hang
it all out there but in terms of where I
would put my efforts for today in the
future and sadly when I think about my
own mixed-race children is to make sure
that they don't have to go through what
I went through I've been extremely
fortunate but when I got into politics
it was very much very clearly explained
to me you don't want to be the black
politician and I didn't want to be
either I wanted to be the politician who
happened to be black and you know he
talked about experiences of racism I
experienced a lot of it but I had to
treat a lot of it as the cost of doing
business and the more painful side of
things the more helpful side of things I
didn't confront you know I learned to
smile to deflect from them I learned to
just walk away I don't want my children
to grow up in a world that is like that
address we face today you learn to be
the smiling black politician David Oh
yellow you wanted to come in there I saw
you raise your hand yes I just wanted to
comment on what Sam just said there yes
yeah taking down those statues doesn't
necessarily move the needle when it
comes to the criminal justice system but
like I said earlier it's about
dismantling systems of oppression what
the prime minister said there about the
distortion of history a Great Britain no
greater no country has done this better
when it comes to the distortion of
history when it comes to the fact that
Great Britain as it stands today was
built on the blacks of black people was
built on the backs of the resources it
pillaged from Africa with colonialism
being the blanket excuse and us pledging
allegiance to to Great Britain and we
built we built modern-day Britain and so
the notion that when brexit hits people
are telling my brother go back to where
you came from when it was built on the
backs of our ancestors
that's a distortion of history that's
something that people are not talking
about we're not talking about the fact
that Great Britain as a as a country
that has limited resources built itself
to Great Britain on the backs of Indians
of Africans and all of the other
colonies that it that it had that's a
distortion of history a much more
egregious distortion of history than the
notion of taking down statues that
should never have been there in the
first place on the basis of what Britain
says it wants to be and who it is the
fact of the matter is this is about
going forward who do we want to be what
do we want to be how do we want the next
generation to perceive the country we
are we can't say things and then
demonstrate it differently by what we
celebrate we can't celebrate that and
then expect them to be different when
they're walking past it every day it
must be torn down it must be professor
sugar I know you want to come in there
but I do want to go back to our audience
and I want to see what they think of
this actually we just want to do a straw
poll by way of a show of hands audience
do you think that that statues of anyone
who's expressed racist views whatever
they've achieved in life should be taken
down hands up if you think that should
be the case
almost almost to all of you 75 to 80% of
you hands up there agreeing that statues
of previous slavers should be brought
down thank you for that straw poll well
let's move on to another question now
from our audience here and this comes
from Ruth a big burner from West
Yorkshire Ruth what's your question good
evening everyone and it links very much
to what's been discussed why won't the
UK's National Curriculum educators
pupils as the full facts of the UK's
involvement in the transatlantic slave
trade and also the British Empire
why don't we allow our students to think
critically about the past in order to
forge a better future
professor sugar I think it's because
history performs a different and I think
very worrying function in Britain
compared to other countries we don't use
our history to ask questions about how
our nation came to be what it is we
don't use history as a vehicle to ask
ourselves why but rose to power we use
history to make ourselves feel good
about ourselves
history is a place we go for a
recreation not to ask difficult
questions and what that means is if
history is a place of comfort you need
to remove from it all of the facts all
of the episodes that are uncomfortable
that a discomforting and that means the
history of empire means the history of
the atlantic slave trade
it means the history of the horrific
violence that under cut Empire it means
the removal of the fact that Britain was
winning concentration camps in Kenya
within living memory all of plans gets
in the way of history being a place of
comfort and of course those stories are
the stories that explain how people like
myself and mentioned the audience came
to be here that the bits of the history
that explained how Britain is seen by
billions of people across the world and
also they are the most important bits of
history that everybody needs to hear
because we need to hear these hard
truths we've convinced ourselves that we
are the only nation in the whole of
history who's only ever done good and we
honestly believe that and people get
hurt when you suggest Britain like every
other country ever has done some good
things and some bad things we've come to
believe in a fairy tale and we call it
history Carib like its are you nodding
there do you recall that the history you
were taught at school look I have a
ten-year-old who's in year five and you
know we've had a lot of debate over the
last couple of weeks about what's
happened in the US and then talked about
you know our history in the UK and you
know there's always World Book Day and
there's always lots of events which
would have celebrate moments in history
and I actually brought my son a book
about Windrush because it's an area that
he's not ought and it's an area where
you know my mum and dad followed the
wind brush generation and the influence
of the Caribbean on the UK it's not
discussed and it's not taught and it's a
part of history that I'd like my son to
know about to understand the
contribution of his granddad and grandma
and the people that came before him to
UK history he's taught about American
history which is great because global
awareness is good but we're not taught
about the UK at school so something
that's very real which is why I was
knotting because it's it's been based on
discussions that we've had over the last
couple of weeks very real very live
discussions about understanding how
we're here and understanding our way of
Union and unfortunately having the
conversation that not everyone will see
him as equal to them and the word
Windrush only coming into public
consciousness in in the last a couple of
years or so well let's stay with
education and we've got a teacher in the
audience just starting out in fact Kym
Lauren and what's your perception of the
curriculum as it stands now as a student
many of us are committed to social
justice
and that's why I'm here today so in
light of the issues highlighted by the
black lives matter movement I feel that
now we need support more than ever to
review and deliver a much more
progressive curriculum which reflects
our multicultural Britain today Kim
thank you Sam Jimmy we need to go back
to basics and start with education start
at the beginning well that's absolutely
true and the way in which you change
people's minds fundamentally is by how
you educate them and what you expose
them to and that is all aspects of our
curriculum I think when I look at what
happens for example every year there is
the UN Day Against Discrimination and
most organizations most schools will
probably do something on that day and
then move on but Britain is a
multicultural country now if you take
the arrival of the Windrush in 1948 as
the symbolic birth of multicultural
Britain it's been a multicultural
country for a very long time and I think
that our education needs to reflect that
not just in terms of sort of one day a
year or one particular part of the
curriculum but throughout it to reflect
the multicultural aspects and dimensions
of this country and going back to the
point about history I absolutely agree
that and as I've said that means
steadying or everything that you're
proud of but also the things that you
would rather sweep under the carpet all
of that meat that needs to be discussed
in the education system if we are going
to become a country that is at ease with
itself so and Rima mentioning their
Black History Month a lots of black
people saying that they're not black for
one month of the year they're black for
12 months of the year David Oyelowo you
wanted to come in there yeah I just
wanted to add the fact that you know for
me as someone born in the UK I'm
incredibly proud of
British heritage a lot of us who are
born in the UK who identify as British
we are so proud of our heritage and you
know sometimes the notion is that to
bring up as Sam just mentioned there
some of the darker sides of whether it's
British history or here in America the
history here is to feel shame or to
somehow denigrate that society or
community that the fact of the matter is
I want to be proud of being British
and I want to be proud of of the Britain
that it wants to be going forward we we
have all as individuals you know that
the Bible says all have sinned and
fallen short we have all done things
were not proud of that doesn't discount
you that doesn't write you off that
doesn't cancel you so much of the beauty
that happens within a person as they go
forward into their life is an acceptance
of what they did wrong and who they want
to be and how transcendent they want to
be going forward Great Britain can
actually earn that title going forward
by accepting what it did in the past
acknowledging it moving on from it and
having young people who are now going to
be proud of the Britain we have going
forward as opposed to the Britain we had
in the past and I would say exactly the
same thing here in America that pride is
part of what got us here in the first
place a sort of a communal national
pride and ego that means that you have
to subjugate other people in order to
feel great yourself and I think we're
just better than that and we as black
people as brown people in America and
the UK we simply want to share in the
pie we helped create
it's not about supremacy it's not about
revenge it's just about sharing in what
we helped build David or you know well
thank you very much just need a piece of
that pie time to take a final question
from our audience at this time from
Curtis DeLeon Curtis what's your
question
good evening panel my question is what
next can racism ever be tackled without
the active support of majority white
people standing up and speaking out okay
let's put that final question to the
panel Karen black it can racism really
ever be tackled
without the support majority white
people standing up and actually speaking
out look we in order to make a change we
need allies it really is a simple as
that and if I think about my own world
and the business world and the
advertising industry and marketing
communications as I said earlier less
than four percent sorry less than five
percent of senior leaders in my industry
come from an ethnic minority background
so that minority cannot change
everything for the majority we just
can't so one thing which is really
important is ally ship we need each
people to stand with us to help make
that change I have seen in the last few
weeks my leaders WPP have get involved
with more listening circles be involved
in more safe rooms that we've been
running for our black colleagues to hear
for themselves what is happening to hear
the outpouring of grief and they've been
spurred into more action there was
always an underlying thought about more
inclusiveness and making sure that we
are open but the last few weeks because
they've literally been spurred into
action and heard it for themselves a
commitment to action and making change
real commitment to making change and we
are talking about allies ship training
bystander training to make sure that all
of those everyday moments of and I hate
the term microaggression because they're
not micro to the person on the end of
them but those everyday insidious
incidents of racism and inequality that
the majority see them
understand them hear them and call it
out and so I I genuinely believe that
you do need allies you do need the
majority to make the change because this
is not a black issue it's a social issue
it's an issue that affects all of
society Karen just so it can't just be
left to a point on that point where
we're looking for solutions give us your
one solution aside from allied ship
Peters check so it's something that June
Sarpong said in her brilliant book
diversify check your circle who are the
closest for people that you go to at
work when you want to have a sounding
board when you want to get advertised
when you want to talk about what went
right what went wrong who are those four
people if those four people are very
similar to you in terms of background in
terms of social class in terms of
Education in terms of race and we're not
that you're not doing anything to help
create more inclusion and more diversity
Drive of diversity check your circle and
make a difference that you have more
diversity of thought
thank you check your circle professor on
a show go what would your solution be
well the thing I would have asked even
before the murder of George Floyd is
amazingly what's happening which is
learning and listening the the reading
lists being passed around online the the
the huge sales or any other lodges book
is top of the of the of the charts today
the most bought book in Britain I would
have dreamed just a few weeks ago that
all people of all backgrounds will be
willing to meet about racism how it
works systemically read about black
history and incredibly that appears to
be what's happening in the scale
I couldn't imagine but I think it's
happening actually because of the big
issue here which is this is generational
change who was it who brought down the
static of constant it was the young who
were reading and buying these books it's
the young who has decided that they
don't really want to live in this system
whether they're black or white they
don't want to participate in this system
or benefit from it never mind be suffer
suffer from it
it's gonna jump in there just gonna jump
in there so we can get to more solutions
first from David or yellower well like
I've said before we are dealing with
systems of oppression they have been
designed and they have been built and
they were not built by black people they
were built by white people people bulk
at that and it's not that you're saying
to every white person alive now that you
built it but you benefit from it and
what we are saying is that you have to
acknowledge that accept that because the
reason it was built was to harness power
what we are now asking as black people
is for you to cede power to share power
to allow us in whether it's my industry
or any of the other pot the political
arena the advertising arena the sports
arena allow us to share and that is part
of what is going to enable us to move
forward together
it all ties back to education you have
to accept that there are certain
constructs whether it's the class system
in the UK
whether it's colonialism whether its
apartheid whether it's enslaved people
there are racist containers that we've
all been living in that need to be
dismantled in order for us to build
something we do so sorry we are running
out of time rapidly thank you very much
for that and thank you to our audience
for their questions and stories your
contribution was in valuable great to
have you with us thanks especially to
our panelists tonight David or Jana whoo
Karen blackett professor on a sugar and
Sam Zima thank you all so what have we
learned this evening well we've heard
how deeply racism still exists but we've
also heard ideas on how to put the bat
right including more and better
community policing thank you for
watching good night